[Music]
this is a Dutch Junction design or at
least it's pretty similar to many
junctions that you'll find throughout
the Netherlands that have to deal with
cars cyclists and pedestrians in pretty
large volumes and in a safe and equal
way and it's something that I really
wanted to make in city skylines for I
would say about two pretty big reasons
one of them is just pretty having
personal since I'm Dutch myself and I
might have too much of a thing for
infrastructure in general and I actually
like to take my bike wherever I go
almost every day another reason is kind
of because this is something that hasn't
really been done so often in city
skylines yet and it's something that I
wanted to try from a gameplay
perspective and maybe to try and spread
the idea of such intersections a little
bit and why I really like the philosophy
behind it maybe that's because I'm Dutch
maybe it's because I'm such a cycling
fan or maybe it's just because I think
it's really interesting material to
think about in terms of city planning
it's definitely not perfect but I try to
get as much of the philosophy in there
while also trying to make a good looking
intersection only thing that you
shouldn't pay too much attention to is
the buses I know that they do that thing
where they kind of fly around and go
into the ground I'm not entirely sure
how to fix that I tried many things but
nothing really worked but in any case
I'll try to explain it more as we get
into the time lapse and I'll show you
how it's all done so without further ado
let's get into it
[Music]
alright so starting off I'm laying the
foundation for the actual functioning
core of this interchange
I think the usual common practice for
city skylines is to just build your
interchanges out of the roads that you
get maybe more the roads a little bit
and add some assets to it but not really
make them fundamentally different and
what I was really happy about with mass
transit is the new addition of the road
color changing model which actually
allows you to remove the markings on
your highway and if you combine this
with culpable s fault and the movement
modes and all kinds of asset mods to
spice things up a little bit I think you
can actually make a core functioning
sort of underground programming for the
cars so that your junction is actually
going to be functioning and then just
make that all invisible and build the
entire look of the junction just out of
assets so I really just use the highway
pieces because that allows me to change
their color and also remove all of the
markings as the background of where the
cars are going to go but the rest is
really just going to filled
be filled quite a bit by probable s4 and
really just be made using custom lines
and assets just to get the exact touch
look it's also a bit of a bit of a I
guess a solution to the problem that
city skylines has inversely where you
don't get more lanes just blow off for
traffic lights which is very unfortunate
it's one of the things that I is really
one of my biggest gripes about the
traffic assuming game so that kind of
helps as well but it also just means
that you know whatever kind of details I
add to the junction to add that sort of
touch flair to it
the cars are still going to use this
Junction only problem is some of the
nodes are so close together and even
though I managed to fix the z-fighting
with the probable s4 pieces the cars
simply just don't really understand
what's going on here and there's a
similar case for the arrows because I
can't remove some of the arrows and I
also can't change their directions which
is which is a pretty big problem it's
not a very big problem I was able to
remove most of
but some are still pointing in different
directions than the part of the road is
going south quite unfortunate you'll
notice for instance that the top left
and bottom right arrows are pointing and
weird other directions but yeah so get
to the actual junction itself because
there's a lot of introduction that I
want to talk about here the general idea
for the junction is quite simple but
it's it's based on a very famous video
even at this point which is from the
view from the psychopath home blog which
is a really cool blog about cycling
infrastructure and they made a video
about Dutch chunking dutch junction
design in its like psycho friendly way
i'll post that in the description and it
has about 400,000 views and quite a bit
more and it's kind of well known it's
not the most well-known example of Dutch
Junction design if not for the fact that
it's not entirely touched problem with
the video is that it has been understood
quite a bit or misunderstood quite a bit
and also been applied in some wrong ways
it's not really a guide as to how to
make a Dutch Junction but it's
apparently from the creators of the blog
itself taken out of context since it's
really just an idea on the philosophies
behind that Junction design and a way to
turn a standard us Junction into
something that is more like the Dutch
protected Junction design which is lot
better for cyclists that said the entire
design of that Junction including the
very idea of having traffic lights and
protected Islands in the middle of the
traffic junction it's something that's
very old fashioned in the Netherlands
right now that's not to say that it
doesn't exist anymore it's just not that
common and many of these kinds of
interchanges are right now being removed
to be replaced by roundabouts which
handle more volume than a regular
intersection and they're also just more
safe so that's one thing to note about
this intersection I just really wanted
to try something like this and do it a
little bit different than that video
still applying some of the base
philosophies that make it a Dutch design
which I'll get into in a bit but at the
same time widening it up a little bit
because that video even though it makes
some great points and I think it
explains really well what makes the
Dutch design work but it's it's on a
very tight space and if you just look at
the look of the junction I don't think
that's where the Dutch news of it comes
at all it's really in how it functions
so let's get into the nitty-gritty
details then in the middle we just have
a somewhat standard Junction you can
just make right turns with those
separate turns you can go straight
pretty easily and if you want to make a
left-hand turn you just kind of cross
the middle of the junction just like
that
we've got a slightly less busy road
going horizontal here and a slightly
more busy road going vertical as you can
see by the fact that I added two extra
lanes on the vertical one on each side
and then comes the important bit and
that is the cycle lanes or the bike
lanes around the entire thing and this
is really where the Dutch genius comes
in and where the importance of it comes
in the crosswalks or I'm not sure what
you call it for bicycles I mean you
don't really walk there but anyway the
crossings for for cyclists are quite a
bit far from the the center of the
intersection which actually works in a
way since it means that cars stopping at
the traffic lights which are a little
bit ahead of the interchange can see the
cyclists ahead and what's especially
important and this is one thing that
distinguishes it from the standard
design presented in the video is that
the cycle lanes are very well separated
from the roads and this is something
which is really quite crucial even even
if the cycle links are pretty close to
the roads you often find that there is
some kind of physical barrier between
the two there's a slightly raised
pavement between the two or what's also
very common is really to do you have
some shrubbery or other kinds of foliage
parks between the road and the bike
lanes which is an extra method of adding
some safety to it
in which this has as well it also has
the advantage of making returns which
you take as a cyclists very wide so even
though you can't make a left-hand turn
instantly as you see you have to first
go straight and then take the left-hand
turn so you have to cross a road twice
it does mean that there are way less
conflict pointer and there are way less
places where you could potentially bump
into a car and you can keep your speed
pretty well on it as well since it's
quite round and curvy you have to do a
little switch to the right if you want
to make a left-hand turn but it's really
not that bad and as the cyclist myself
it's one thing I really had is
intersections where they're so tight
that you really have to slow down
especially after a Brit or something
we're just making some awesome speed
anyway that's totally beside the point
those are basically the ways to
hopefully make this slightly better
intersection for cyclists not only in
saving time allowing more volume but
also in making it safer now just along
the sides of that you can see the zebra
stripes for the regular pedestrian
crossings and that just about makes the
entire design of the interchange and
it's it's quite a wide design especially
since everything is so separated even
the different kinds of roads are
separated you'll see here so you also
have these little islands for the
pedestrians for instance the cross and
to look once again for any oncoming cars
so that you never have to worry about
cars coming from the left and the right
at the same time and yeah that's really
the simple design behind the junction
itself one thing that I do I do want to
note though is the fact that I added
trees on the islands which is something
which is unheard of or at least it's not
unheard of it happens but if they are
there at all they should be smaller with
the core rule of not breaking the line
of sight too much with these trees I
think they do break the line of sight
too much they're just too bulky and they
start having leaves too close to the
ground
only problem is I like to look them too
much so I can
when we form over function there yeah
that's technically a one big flaw of the
disjunction that aside I'm trying to get
the crossings in in a realistic way you
also see that they do have separate
traffic lights so as a cyclist you're
really only be stopping directly next
good right there and will be quite a few
meters ahead of the cars that have to
stop nearby which is also very handy now
I know that I said that you know this
this design is a bit outdated now which
it technically is but it still is used
quite a bit I base this mostly off of
examples in Horla turn house alarm which
is very far away from me but also some
closer examples to me in the center of
Ireland next and half a start in red
akattak shout out anybody who knows
these places but um basically there are
still similar designs that you see in
the Netherlands because it's still out
there it just happens to be that you
know there are some newer better designs
which you can build and sit in the same
space to allow for the same or better
volumes and in a safer way I just really
thought this would be an interesting
intersection to talk more about such
intersection design and why I think the
Dutch intersection design works quite
well and yeah it's really also just
based on some real-life intersections
now I wanted to build some quick houses
over here as well not really because I'm
going to build an entire Dodge City or
anything like that that would be quite a
bit of effort but because this kind of
gives a bit of context to the
interchange one thing that I would say
about this interchange is that it's more
of an intern or an inner-city
interchange if you will since it has the
bike lanes around all of the sites so
naturally you'd also think that you'd
want to bike around all of the sites
these are also one-way bike lanes one of
my biggest gripes with these with this
game has always been met it only has to
wait bike lanes and bike lanes in the
Netherlands are more commonly one-way
bike lanes on either side of the road
but yeah because of that it's more of
like inner
City sort of design if you are more
outside of the city you'd usually just
find a two way bike lane a bit further
away from the road but over here I think
it works to just tack this very small
residential area which looks a bit such
also something that I should note about
this which is quite interesting
I remember I've talked about this a long
time ago in the first episode of my
participe series but what's also quite
interesting about this is there are all
kinds of traffic regulations and rules
and guidelines in the Netherlands as per
usual per country but one that is quite
important and quite regular rigorously
followed in the Netherlands is that of
three different types of roads I don't
know any of the English translations for
this but you've basically got roads that
are meant as long-distance transport
things like highways and more like
prevention or provincial kind of
highways things like that then you've
got like more transport roads which can
just be in the middle of the city and
you'll have cycle lanes around the sides
and such but there won't be any houses
right next to those types of roads
that's basically the type of road that
this interchange meets at four different
places but then there's also the last
type of Road and this is often a brick
road instead of asphalt and it's also an
even shared space it has much lower
volumes and it's really only meant for
local traffic he'll they'll usually be
built in such a way that you can't
actually use them to get across town and
they'll just be built in some labyrinth
of ways with only a few entries into
each neighborhood so that car volumes
are minimized to right next to houses
which is quite cool but um that type of
road is basically the brick type of road
that I wanted to use for a small
residential neighbourhood over there
just to see how it would no kind of look
next to the interchange which we're
building here now since I also wanted to
add a little bit of context to the
interchange and not just build the
intersection should be itself I also
wanted to add some nature around it one
of those things was actually making a
small ditch because
everywhere in the Netherlands and that's
something that I was never really able
to do until recently we actually got an
amazing asset in the shape of some water
which you can place in a small ditch
actually make it look like a small dirty
landscape which is quite nice I'm sorry
that I don't know any of the creators of
the mods I'll post a link in the
description of to my new Dutch asset
series which is a collection that I
still maintain on Steam for some kind of
new Dutch series in City skylines don't
don't have your hopes up the hope
because I'm not planning any of the
swords I've just been keeping that list
for over a year maybe one day it happens
but it's an updated list with many of
the assets which are used in here as
well and if you're wondering how to sort
of create this intersection there are a
couple very important mods and assets
that I should definitely note one of
them is of course the road colours
changer since it allows you to use
highways the way I did another one is
the smooth and regular faded lines which
I don't know who made them actually I'm
going to lick that up right now but yeah
those are the lines that I used to throw
much of the interchange in section and
what's also very important is move it
you absolutely have to have move it's to
move things around in any good way and I
think that's really one of the most
crucial things especially in this build
another one that was quite funny and
this is going to be exceptionally hard
to actually find oh there we go the the
smooth lines were by move with a
copyright sign but yeah that will be
down in description as well but another
thing which was quite important here was
a shark Junction angles to be able to do
the things which I do with roads at all
and have energy to put things over each
other the prop line tool actually have
lines of well basically all the lines
that I draw and that's really some of
the most important stuff there's also
probable asphalt to fill everything up
and some kerb assets but I've got all
kinds of kerb assets and they're all
more or less work there's quite a bit of
that stuff
workshop as well I think the smooth
lines are especially important though
since it allows you to draw your own
thing so for example the shark teeth as
we call it which are the giveaway
markings in the Netherlands are lines
that you don't really have in the game
so you need to make those yourself in
the same kind of goes for all of these
different white fields in the middle of
the interchange intersection damnit as
well so yeah those are reliefs on the
most important things I know this isn't
really that much of tutorial I don't
think you should take it as one though I
think this should hopefully at least I
think that would be amazing be some kind
of inspiration as to what you can do in
this game especially with some of the
new mods and all of the efforts that we
have nowadays you can really transform
the intersections and everything in this
game beyond recognition and that's what
one of the things I love most about this
game anyway that's just about it for the
time lapse so thank you guys for
watching I hope you maybe learn
something from this got some inspiration
got some ideas on how in general Dutch
Street design is and maybe we'll see
this kind of design a little bit more
common in the City skylines community
I'll probably mess with this a little
bit more I hope to build some kind of
runabout sometime soon and experiment a
bit more with this kind of stuff but for
now this has religious been a quick
one-off then I wanted to do for fun and
because it's something that I really
wanted to test so yeah thank you guys
again for watching and I will see you
all next time